Please welcome Mark Cuban!
(upbeat music)
(audience applauds)
(Mark laughs)
Oh.
At times we have learned all of us
are a little too intimidated to go up to someone,
I saw you in a restaurant one time eating,
I didn't wanna bother you.
Oh, that breaks my heart,
I'm such a huge fan.
I'm such a fan of yours!
I'm the bigger fan!
Well, maybe as a neon sign says in my entry way
that I hand wrote and turned into a neon sign,
"Timing is everything."
Okay, well, here we are.
Thank you,
I'm so glad to make it great.
I am so glad to be here.
Okay, so I have to leap right in
and ask you about the prescription drug program
that you have started.
Yeah, costplusdrugs.com.
Tell us about it.
Thanks for bringing up.
So like all of us,
we've looked at the price of medications
and they just keep on going up,
so about three and a half years ago,
I started working with Dr. Alex Oshmyansky,
so with the way prescription drug pricing works right now,
is there's these things called pharmacy benefit managers
that act as a middle man,
and they distort all the pricing,
so we said, "We'll become a pharmacy benefit manager,
but we're gonna take out all the price distortions."
So as a result, if you go to costplusdrugs.com,
we have about 110 drugs that we sell now,
that'll go up to 2,000 by year end,
and when you add it all up,
some of our prices are 90, 95% lower
than traditional drug pricing.
(audience applauds)
This is literally why I'm so enamored with you.
I found out of an interesting fact doing research on you.
You purchased a small town in Texas.
Yeah, Mustang, Texas.
Why did you buy the town?
Okay, so I'm gonna sound corny again,
but one of my buddies,
I've been a basketball junkie my entire life,
so I go play pickup basketball,
and one of my buddies that I played pick up basketball with
got cancer and was close to dying,
and his only real asset was this town, Mustang, Texas.
And I'm like, "Well, I can help Marty,
and I could buy this town."
So I bought the town!
It was a cool concept, right?
It was like, it's the only town in all of the state of Texas
that is available for sale,
and so I bought it.
And what we do with it ties back to "Shark Tank",
maybe, we're trying to decide.
So there's a guy on "Shark Tank", Dino Dan,
or Dino Don, and he makes the animatronic dinosaurs,
like if you go to zoos and everything
and you see of these huge animatronic dinosaurs
that look and sound real,
and we did a "Shark Tank" episode on it,
and I invested in them.
So we haven't worked it through yet,
but there's a chance we might change Mustang, Texas
to Dinosaur, Texas,
and do one of just having all these big, huge,
"Jurassic Park" like dinosaurs.
Okay you have a small town now, are you the mayor?
Are you the sheriff?
No, I got one of my buddies.
Do you have a thing?
No.
Do you wear a star?
(Mark laughing)
What happens when you purchase a small town?
How are you then responsible for it?
I made one of my buddies the mayor,
which basically means he's responsible
for cleaning the trash and keeping it clean.
That's the job of the mayor of Mustang, Texas.
That's why we might change it to Dinosaur, Texas,
but that's a long shot.
(upbeat music)